Democrats are very anxious to stop Brett
Kavanaugh from getting onto the Supreme
Court they don't have many mechanisms to
stop him so they are misrepresenting
apparently his views on abortion just
last week Senator Kamla Harris of
California tweeted out this video it
suggested that Cavanaugh viewed birth
control pills as a form of abortion
watch filling out the form would make
them complicit in the provision of the
abortion inducing drugs that they were
as a religious matter objected to
Hillary Clinton who's got some free time
joined in the attack sedation at this
quote I want to be sure we're all clear
about something that Brett Kavanaugh
said in his confirmation hearings last
week he referred to birth control pills
this quote abortion inducing drugs that
set off a lot of alarm bells for me and
it should for you too
well what Clinton and Harris aren't
telling you is that they're taking
Kavanagh grossly out of context now
that's usually an excuse in Washington
when someone's caught saying something
embarrassing or taking me out of context
but in this case it's literally true
Cavanaugh was actually setting the view
of a religious organization priests for
life the phrase was not his or his
personal view apparently it certainly
wasn't his phrase since they won't show
and here's the full clip pay attention
to the first two words of it they said
filling out the form would make them
complicit in the provision of the
abortion inducing drugs that they were
as a religious matter objected to they
said the critical two words Dana Perino
host the daily briefings javasan the
five everyday you already love and trust
her thankfully she's been following this
pretty closely so David I wonder if this
is counterproductive something this
obviously misleading interesting you
said that just about 10 minutes ago the
hill newspaper just put out a story
headlined that leftist attacks against
Cavanaugh could face a backlash for them
and I think that that's absolutely true
first of all comma Harris was a
prosecutor I think words seriously
matter
she tainted with the evidence that
should be grounds for her being thrown
out cory booker also was found to be
trying to say something that turned
not to be true in his I am Spartacus
moment it is pretty shocking that it was
two days after Carla Harris even
admitted that they had done this at
Hillary Clinton then tweeted it and I
saw it even people on the left saying
this is why you lost okay we like enough
with you we don't need any of that yes
but one thing you didn't mention is that
there's a group up in Maine that is
basically trying to bribe the senator
there senator Collins into voting
against Kavanagh she's not necessarily
inclined to do so she's Republican she's
basically said he's not said anything
that would cause her to vote no but they
started a crowdsourcing site
crowdfunding excuse me where they would
raise a million dollars and donate it to
her opponent if she's but the only
reason way that the guy gets the money
is if she votes no which she basically
store they're trying to extort her
they're saying talk to clean a Mitchell
about in-kind contributions there is
even a question is is this even legal
and it might just also be a publicity
stunt but they did raise over a million
dollars the phone calls to her office
you should hear if you read that article
some of them are just so vulgar that I
do think it is a backlash they don't
have a way to fight against Brett
Kavanaugh I understand they're very
frustrated but the way to win is
actually win at the ballot box you're
not going to win here interesting so why
I mean there are some smart people in
the Democratic Party I know and they
know that barring some unforseen act of
god he is gonna sit on that Court I
don't can't control that so why are we
doing this well part of the reason is
because the base is very agitated and
they want someone who will fight and
that is why you might not want to count
out Kamala Harris in 2020 she has shown
that she is willing to fight very dirty
and she doesn't have any shame in doing
so and perhaps that might be what it
takes because remember the whole thing
of at least she fights even if the
fighting is wrong a they don't care that
the evidence was tainted
that's just it just it it seems to me
that that shouldn't be reward I mean you
don't I mean like yeah I understand
toughness as a prerequisite to winning
that is absolutely you have to be tough
but do you really want a system that
encourages people to be more dishonest
and they would be otherwise and let's
give a little shout out here too
the media who actually covered this
story about Karla Harrison this video
about Brett Kavanaugh a staffer in
senator McConnell's office a senior
staffer saw this thought it sounded
weird went back and checked and alerted
the fact checkers and including the
Washington Post and they gave Camilla
Harris four Pinocchios but a weird thing
is happening it's almost as if getting
four Pinocchios is a badge of honor
that's not something that I admire but
watch her I think that she is not
someone to be counted out yeah it's
scary actually Dana thank you very much
that analysis good night